>> WE NOW RETURN TO CHARLES
DICKENS A CHRISTMAS CAROL.
>> OH, SPIRITS, PLEASE
I WANT TO BE A BETTER MAN.
I WANT TO LIVE
I'M ALIVE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT I'M ALIVE
THANK YOU, SPIRITS
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING ME THE
WAY!
OH, I'M AS LIGHT AS A FEATHER.
I'M AT GIDDY AS A MAN.
I WILL CHANGE.
I SWEAR I'LL CHANGE.
I HOPE FS NOT TOO LATE
OH, YOU, LAD
YOU DOWN THERE
>> ME?
>> YES, YOU.
COME HERE.
WHAT DAY IS TODAY?
>> WHY, IT'S CHRISTMAS DAY, SIR.
>> AH, CHRISTMAS, THEN I HAVEN'T
MISSED IT.
MY DEAR BOY, YOU KNOW THE PRIZED
GOOSE IN THE WINDOW DOWN THE
STREET
>> THE ONE AS BIG AS ME?
>> THAT'S THE ONE.
GO AND BUY IT SO THAT TINY TIM
AND HIS FAMILY CAN HAVE A FEAST.
>> WHAT SHALL I BUY IT WITH,
SSI
SIR?
I'M SO POOR.
>> WHY WITH THIS, OF COURSE.
>> AHH
OH, MY GOD
WHATTHE HELL ARE YOU DOING
I'M BLIND!
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU CATCH IT
>> YOU'RE BLAMING ME.
>> HERE.
TAKE THIS FOR YOUR MEDICAL
BILLS.
>> WHAT'S THAT
AHH!
OH, MY GOD
>> THIS CRAZY OLD MAN IS
WHIPPING COINS INTO THE EYES OF
ORPHANS.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW HE WAS AN
ORPHAN.
>> OH, YEAH, LIKE I LOOK LIKE I
HAVE LIVING PARENTS?
>> HEY, SCROOGE, JUST THOUGHT
YOU WOULD CHECK IN ON YOU AND
SEE -- OH, MY GOSH.
>> SOMEONE ARREST THAT MAN
HE'S BLINDING CHILDREN FOR
SPORT.
>> HE'S ALWAYS BEEN A CRUEL OLD
MAN.
>> LET ME GUESS, YOU TOSSED THE
COIN WAY UP IN THE AIR, RIGHT?
THAT'S A CLASSIC MISTAKE
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS TOSS THE
COIN STRAIGHT DOWN
NOW WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I COULDN'T SEE WHAT HAPPENED.
>> HE'S BLINDING THE WHOLE TOWN,
HE IS.
>> THAT WAS MY BAD
HERE, KID.
PUT SOME ICE ON IT.
>> AHH
>> THAT WAS HIM.
>> YEAH, THEY CAN'T SEE ME
BECAUSE I'M A GHOST, SO YOU LOOK
LIKE A TOTAL SIGH OWE PATH NOW.
>> IS IT TRUE, MR. SCROOGE
ARE YOU BLINDING PEOPLE FOR FUN?
OF COURSE NOT, TINY TIM.
I'M A CHANGED MAN.
NOW, TAKE THIS MONEY TO FIX YOUR
LEGS
I'LL THROW IT ON THE GROUND AND
YOU CAN PICK IT UP, OKAY
>> SCROOGE JUST THREW TINY TIM
INTO THE SUER.
>> HE'S THE DEVIL, HE IS.
>> MY NEW ADVICE IS LAWYER UP.
>> IT'S FINE
I CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS.
LET'S EVERYONE KEEP QUIET ABOUT
THIS WHOLE INCIDENT, SHALL WE,
AND I'LL MAKE IT WORTH YOUR
WHILE.
>> PLEASE STOP YELLING AND
THROWING SHINY OBJECTS
YOU'RE GOING TO SPOOK THE HORSE!
>> OKAY.
WELL, WE'VE ALL LEARNED A LOT
TODAY, HAVEN'T WE?
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT LESSON
IS -- MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> APPLE PAY
NEVER USE COINS AGAIN.